hi I'm this is a GU Hayashi from Hammond
with some research AUSA so today I'm
present in a poster titled
pharmacological moderation of pain
related brain activation in non-human
primate models of pain so in this study
we have developed several non-human
primate models for pain and to support
the drug research and development
activities for analytics the the reason
why we chose non-human primates is that
an instrument primates
much closer to human compared to other
technical models and shares many
features of physiological and
pathological features with human
diseases so in this in this study we
have developed models for endometriosis
posture operator pain and the oxtail
protein induced peripheral neuropathy
neuropathic pain so the the main
objective of this study is to compare
the pain associated behavior with the
pain related to brain activity in each
models to CFT the measurements of brain
activity can be used as a objective
measurement of pain so let's look at the
results section so for in Demetrios
models we assess the pain behavior using
the pressure testing where the pressure
was applied to the abdominal region of
the animal as you can see in the in the
graph so the the the threshold for the
pain related response is reduced which
means the animals
experience the pain with the pressure
applied to the abdominal region so this
response bridge was improved with the
morphine administration or the energies
which is upon home no therapy using the
clinic so these two compounds should be
energetic effects in the behavior
testing so then we tested the they the
brain activity of the animals using the
functional MRI and as you can see and in
the the figure in the middle section we
can see the brain activation in the
region called insular cortex and also
the thermos and the animals and these
brain activation was attenuated with
mouthing or the energist treatment which
is in line with the behavior testing
and for the post-operative pain model
which is in the bottom a middle bottom
of the posture so in this model the
again the pain really pain associated
behavior was assessed with the pressure
testing as in the end of interest model
so in this model we administered the
morphine and the morphine showed the
analgesic effect as shown in the bar
graph in contrast pre gambling which is
also the analgesic used in the clinic
was not SKS in this particular model in
the end the pain pressure testing the DS
of this finding is in line with the the
brain activation measured with
functional MRI so in this model we see
the brain activation in the insular
cortex and also the distinct cingulate
cortex and the beaze activation was
reduced with malfini there with the the
Dupree gaveling de the brain activation
in the insular cortex was not reduced
which means that the initial context is
more related to the pain associated
painting print perception then finally
we also look at the oxide plotting
induced peripheral neuropathy model so
in this model we induce the called LD
Nia by injecting oxide platting into the
the animal the in this model we assess
the pain behave pain associated behavior
with so called tail emergent testing
where the tail of the animal words
immerse into the cold water and
avoidance response with the the the
withdrawal latency today the avoidance
response with recorded as a
measurement for pain
so when animals were injected with oxy
plotting the with latency was reduced
which means that animal is experiencing
a pain shown in the graph here and this
behavior was reversed with drugs in
treatment but not with forgetting
treatment and this behavioral testing a
result of behavior testing whereas a
confirmed in line with the brain
activation measured with functional MRI
so as you can see in the middle figure
the the drug setting it's in this models
the brain activation in the insular
cortex region was observed and this
exhibition was reduced with interrupting
treatment but prayer gathering failed to
deactivate this region which means which
in line with the Dino effects of peer
gaveling in the in the behavior testing
to summary to summarize a the
deactivation of unique as well as a
common pain related brain areas appears
across 90 my prime and paint models in
this case endometriosis poster Prairie
pain and oxide parking induce pain and
so the non-human primate brain
activation could be used as an objective
and preclinical marker of pain for
various pain states and and also these
findings show that you know invasive
paint brain imaging Reznick with
functional MRI could also be used as an
objective or marker of pain to guide the
development of analgesic drugs
and potentially to be used to screen
more promising drug candidates to be
tested in the clinical trial thank you
for your attention